so we've known for a long time now that
there are more than 15 or so women who
credibly have accused Donald Trump of
sexual assault or sexual harassment or
molestation sometimes even rising to the
threshold of rape in fact when we
learned that this new book was coming
out all the president's women Donald
Trump and the making of a predator it
was previewed to us that there were
about 25 more women who detailed their
maltreatment by Donald Trump in the book
so we at that point speculated the total
number you know there's the 15 there's
the 25 there might be some overlap maybe
it's 35 women maybe it's 40 total women
considering that some of the women in
the book might already be known to us
previously the book is now out as of two
days ago and it is endlessly more
disgusting than we expected there are so
many women who accuse Donald Trump of
some form of molestation that the book
has a 50 page appendix containing a
total of about 200 women 200 women
making allegations of molestation of
different degrees against the President
of the United States the most
interesting thing about it is that
Donald Trump's MO in most of these cases
is very similar but also he also seems
to be the opposite of a slick or a
smooth operator according to what the
women detail its forcible kissing which
remember Trump is on tape saying when
you're famous you can just kiss them you
just kiss him whatever it includes
groping and genital grabbing remember
again in the tape Trump says grab him by
the you-know-what so that is very much
in line with what Donald Trump has said
he does before it includes setting up
parties and events where he can create
situations of power dynamics with
specific women very much in line to what
he was known to do with Jeffrey Epstein
even on video at a party and I believe
it was the late 90s just standing there
evaluating women with a very
uncomfortable awkward looking Jeffrey
Epstein multiple women who detail
assaults taking place at Donald Trump's
mar-a-lago resort tell similar stories
of waking
and Trump is standing in their bedroom I
mean can you imagine many of the stories
follow the trend that when things aren't
going well in one of Donald Trump's
marriages or relationships the frequency
of these assaults increases and women
are targeted more frequently that's in
line with everything we know including
during rough patches and Donald Trump's
relationship with the now First Lady
Melania Trump as we know sometimes hush
money is involved to make stories go
away sometimes it's physical threats
threats of violence but in the end is
any of this going to matter I mean I'm
not I'm not telling you this because now
this is going to be what takes down from
the guy was elected after saying you can
just grab them and do what you want
evangelical voters who supposedly vote
their values voted for Donald Trump
after he said you just grab them
wherever you want because they don't
actually care about the morality that
they claim to want to legislate so what
difference is it going to make if it's
15 women or 40 women or 207 women or
whatever the number actually ends up
being legally the statute of limitations
on most of these has expired legal
repercussions forget about it unless
there were recent payoffs which could be
campaign finance violations depending on
how it was handled there's not going to
be a single legal repercussion for this
with every single one of these
violations of the emoluments clause that
Trump says is phony with ignoring legal
impeachment subpoenas and Democrats not
enforcing them none of this stuff is
going to make a difference unless and
2-hundred allegations of molestation
against women as well none of it will
make a difference unless it inspires
people to go out and vote in November of
2020 and I know it's almost a daily
thing that I'm saying right now if you
think there could be other repercussions
from something like 200 plus women
alleging that Donald Trump molested them
let me know what they are because I
don't see it between the statute of
limitations between with all of these
other things the fact that they're just
have not
consequences to what Donald Trump has
done and continues to do I see every
single one of these stories about what
Donald Trump has done what Donald Trump
is accused of they are merely proxies to
encourage voting in November of 2020
which is only at this point fifty three
fifty three and a half weeks away that
is the most direct path to removing
Trump and I know I've been saying this
for a long time but do we think that
there's going to be something else in a
short fifty three and a half weeks that
will remove Trump as long as Republicans
continue to stand by him as long as
Trump and his campaign officials and his
administration officials ignore
congressional subpoenas with no
consequences what is it that's going to
remove Trump any more quickly than just
voting the guy out in fifty three and a
half weeks let me know if you have a
different view let me know if you see a
different path to Trump's removal I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and
remember if you have Amazon Prime you
can subscribe free to you to my twitch
channel twitch.tv slash David Pakman you
subscribe with twitch Prime okay if you
have Amazon Prime you pay nothing it
counts as a paid subscription for us a
great way to funnel a little bit of that
Jeff Bezos money into independent media
twitch.tv slash David Pakman subscribed
with twitch Prime we will take a quick
break and be back right after this